yo what's up everybody coming at yeha
here on the chess.com YouTube channel
this is international Master Daniel
wrench and today as you can see from the
title we are here to discuss the French
defense another very Mainline and
popular opening that you must know for
your tournament chess career that you've
been waiting to unleash upon the world
as you dominate your way to the top of
the Chess World well the first thing you
got to do is know the mainline
tournament openings that are used by the
best players in the world and that's the
purpose of our chess openings playlist
here on YouTube the chess.com Channel so
subscribe today and you will be up to
date on everything you need to know so
the French defense occurs after the
moves E4 E6 D4 D5 there are three
Mainline structures that can occur from
the French defense the first being an
advanced structure here which allows
white counterplay and potential space on
the king side particularly with his Pawn
on E5 serving as an anchor for that
attack what do I mean by that usually
when you have a Pawn on E5 that by
definition means there is never a knight
on F6 which by definition means without
a knight on on F6 Black's King side is
harder to defend so whenever white has a
space advantage in the center with a
dark Square chain like this especially
with an E5 Pawn standing at the at the
Forefront of that long spear white will
typically get good kingside counterplay
from Black's perspective he would like
to use the queen side in order to
develop his pieces and to exert more
pressure against White Center with the
eventual goal that white might either
lose that pawn or perhaps give in to
capturing on C5 which in turn any sort
of break like this regardless of when it
happens here wouldn't quite be the most
common way for white to take the pawn is
it would immediately create these
problems but even if it happens down the
road if white ever breaks and and and
gives in and blinks first by capturing
on C5 black will not only gain immediate
space toward the king side because of
this open diagonal but usually the E5
Pawn which as we just said before is
White's catalst for an attack will will
start to become a much weaker Target and
uh a very easy easy plan for black to
develop and and start to put pressure
against that pawn so the first structure
that can be reached is an advanced
structure as I said White's playing on
the king side Black's playing on the
queen side second structure that can be
reached is the exchange structure which
is essentially a symmetrical structure
with very little pull for either side in
terms of uh the Dynamics of the pawns
obviously the open E file because it's
the only open file will be a critical
fighting point for both sides white has
a few different ways to follow up the
exchange structure one of them is just
being to develop pieces and eventually
try to get castled and fight for the uh
the open E file in this
Square um and the other might be to try
to play the move C4 which potentially
invites either an isolated Queen Pawn
type position or a position where black
and white are both defending against the
critical point and pressure surrounding
the D5 Square so we've discussed that a
chain structure can be reached the
exchange structure can be reached and
finally Carol slav structure which is
actually a structure that occurs from
many other Mainline openings we call the
class French structure for this case can
occur if white simply chooses to develop
and defend the E4 Pawn either with
Knight to C3 or Knight to D2 either one
of these moves can be met by captures on
e4 after which we have a structure where
white has two potentially uh more
advanced Pawns in the center gaining
space however black has a very solid
structure will typically try to strike
eventually with either the move C5 or E5
as well as combining that with plans of
putting pressure against the open dwn
that is now a Target along the open D
file the semi-open file for black so
those are the mainline Pawn structures
that can occur from this opening to talk
quickly about the five Mainline opening
variations we'll give them names now
that we've talked about the structures
and the general plans we're going to
outline it quickly for you with the uh
with the names so E5 itself is the
advanced variation of the French and
after C5 C3 Queen to B6 white typically
plays Knight F3 and now after the move
Knight to C6 black is exerting pressure
against the pawn and white has a few
different ways of play here one of them
is and the most popular one is to move
A3 with the idea being to play B4 trying
to eliminate some of the pressure that
black has on this focal point C5 in
doing so he hopes that he can then
refocus his efforts to be completely on
the king side why would A3 and B4 be a
necessary plan for that well if you
don't somehow eliminate some of Black's
pressure here it's very hard to develop
this bishop because of the protection it
needs on the B Pawn and if it's hard to
develop the bishop it's also hard to
develop the Knight as bringing him to A3
as a sideline Square on the edge of the
board and D2 would block the Queen's
protection of this Pawn so you see that
white has trouble developing the pieces
if he doesn't try to eliminate some of
Black's pressure another Mainline move
would be something like Bishop E2 just
developing and dealing with those things
later on the things we highlighted on
the queen side or even the move Bishop
D3 with the idea of retreating it back
to C2 noted should be that black cannot
capture and win this Pawn immediately as
at the end of this variation white has a
discovered check against the king
unleashing the Queen's attack against
the undefended black queen on D4
that you have it is the highlighted most
basic variations of the advanced
variation of the French next we'll talk
about the exchange as I already said
there isn't much more to add about this
except that the structure itself doesn't
have very much pull it's usually a
weapon played when white wants to have
positions with little little losing
chances in regards to uh uh black having
some sort of dynamic play very a very
dry cut position not to say that neither
side can win just that it's more dry
positions and not the most exciting
thing and you know what I don't really
like discussing unexciting positions so
I'm not going to give you much more
information on that line than I've
already given you so the win and work
can occur after Knight to C3 which is
interesting because if black doesn't
choose to capture and play the classical
the move Bishop B4 E5 C5 A3 heads us
into a position that you'll notice looks
very strikingly similar to the advanced
variation with one critical difference
White's Queen side is much weaker in
regards to the pawn structure because
unlike the position before where White
had the same sort of Pawn chain his
pawns were not doubled yet and a little
bit more cohesive in this situation
black will have more Targets on the
queen side potentially the weak C3 pawn
and the isolated a pawn well what did
white gain in return for this further
weak in Queen side the lacking of
Black's dark squared Bishop on the
king's side tends to promote even more
aggressive attacking chances for white
after moves such as Knight E7 for
example the move seven Queen to G4 is
actually the most popular move in this
position immediately exerting pressure
against this week Square intending to
bring all of the pieces with full force
over to the king side and Checkmate
black where he stands so the winner is
one of the most imbalanced and sharp
lines of the French after the moves both
Knight to C3 and Knight to D2 the other
option as I said is to take and after
Knight F6 Bishop G5 Bishop E7 takes
takes we've reached a Mainline classical
variation of the French with another
popular move for black being the move
Knight B to D7 here finally the Tash
French after Knight to D2 if black
chooses not to take he can play Knight
F6 noted should be that the winner will
move Bishop B4 wouldn't make sense here
as the move C3 would L attack the bishop
and unpin the Knight and after the move
Knight F6 E5 Knight to D7 something like
F4 being popular you can reach positions
that are sort of similar to the pawn
chain you reach in advance or a winterer
with one major difference being that
white has has gained extra time for this
move F4 however in doing so he's also
neglected his own development slightly
and therefore black has gained a small
amount of an initiative or let's say
more developed pieces toward the queen
side noted should be the Knight maneuver
I just did there that I didn't play the
Knight to D2 in order to develop this
guy to F3 I intend to bring this guy to
F3 so that both of my Knights can work
together in cohesion in terms of
defending the critical point D4 well
that's it everybody the French just got
rocked in your face camel cake hope you
enjoy it chew on
that hope you enjoyed this video and
I'll see you around on chess.com